Hello?
Hi, Amanda.
How is it going?
Everything is fine.
Cool.
How's your weekend?
What did you do?
I went to the movies with my friends.
What did you watch?
I watched a romantic comedy movie.
Who's in the movie?
Will Smith.
I love him very much.
Oh, you love Will Smith?
Did you watch "Men in Black"?
Of course.
I watched it twice!
You must be really crazy about him.
What movies with him would you recommend?
Do you know "I Am Legend"?
I strongly recommend this movie.
What kind of movie is it?
It's kind of science fiction.
Okay.
Well, so what did you do after watching the movie?
We went to Insa-dong for dinner.
It's a famous traditional street in Korea.
Did you have Korean traditional food for dinner?
Yes, we had bibimbap for dinner.
It was very delicious!
You had a fun weekend!